Kanye West gets labeled alt-right by
Washington Post writer Pat Buchanan
stems for the end of democracy and the
New York Times tells a romantic story
about a lesbian and a transgendered
woman conceiving a child so basically a
normal 2018 news day I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
one thing you can certainly say is that
God has a sense of humor with the news
cycle because every day is an adventure
we'll get to all of the myriad
adventures in just a second first I want
to say thanks to our sponsors over at
Birch gold so let's be real about this
you feel a little bit uncomfortable with
the state of politics right now do you
not you feel like the economy it may be
on a knife's edge maybe you feel like
it's going strong or maybe you just want
to invest for the future well whatever
your case may be you should at least
have some of your money in precious
metals I'm not saying take all your
money out of the stock market stick it
in gold I'm saying you might want to
take some of your money and put it in
precious metals because it's a good
headed hedge against inflation against
government intervention ISM it's a good
hedge against volatility in the market
well if you want to invest in precious
metals there's only one group you should
be talking to and those are my friends
over at Birch gold group they have a
long-standing track record of continued
success thousands of satisfied clients
countless five-star reviews and an A+
rating with the Better Business Bureau
contact Birch gold group right now to
receive a free information kit on
physical precious metals it's a
comprehensive 16 page kit and it shows
how gold and silver can protect your
savings and I can legally move your IRA
or 401k out of stocks and bonds and into
a precious metals IRA if you so choose
you get that no-cost no-obligation kit
go to birchgold.com slash Ben that's
birchgold.com slash Ben again use that
slash Ben to get that free comprehensive
16-page kit ask all your questions once
you get your answers invested my friends
over at Birch gold birchgold.com slash
Ben use the slash Ben's they know that
we sent you okay so there's a serious
question to be asked about what it takes
to be labeled alright these days so as
someone who is quite familiar with the
alright you may recall all the way back
to the 2016 election cycle when the
alt-right and I went out and on a
routine basis mainly because they didn't
like that I was a cook Jew and I didn't
like that they were a bunch of
anti-semitic mine freaks so I'm not fond
of the alright I find the alt-right
despicable and when I say all right I
don't mean people who like memes
I think memes are funny I don't mean
people who voted for Donald Trump
because the vast majority of those
people are not alright I mean people who
are actual racists who believe that
there is a a white supremacy inherent in
the color of your skin which is stupid
and ridiculous and an anti-democratic
well the problem is that the left has
now broadened out the label alright to
apply to anyone so they've labeled me
alright
which is incredibly insane I mean like
fully full-on insane considering I was
the number one target of the all right
in 2016 according to the anti-defamation
league I was the number one recipient of
anti
tweets among Jewish journalists with a
bullet I mean I'm talking 40 percent of
all anti-semitic tweets directed a
journalists many of these from the all
right or directed at me personally and
yet now I am supposed to be believe that
I I'm a member of the alright what made
me a member of the alt-right well made
me a member of the alt-right is that I
am NOT on the left and the latest
beneficiary of this particularly bizarre
line of logic is of course our future
president
Tanya West so a few days ago I warned
you that if you're conservative and you
are supremely just in love with the fact
that Kanye West is saying some mildly
conservative things on Twitter you might
want to hold off you might you might a
great I'm glad he said that on Twitter
but before you start declaring that he's
a presidential candidate before you
start saying he's a celebrity who knows
things you might want to take a look at
his older tweets which include things
like four pillows are hard to sleep on
true true I can't argue with that tweet
but not exactly in line with I would say
the intellectual thinking of the
conservative movement but because Kanye
tweeted these relatively mild things
about how victim mentality is not good
and how you ought to go out and work for
yourself and how he likes Candace Owens
who is the communications director of a
turning point USA working with charlie
quote charlie kirk and both good folks
well now there's a person who's written
for The Washington Post her name is
Molly Roberts and she says that Kanye
West is in all right darling which is
weird since the alright is not
particularly fine of black people but
again this is the way that the left
shrinks that Overton Window the Left
says there is a window of acceptable
rhetoric and if you're not on the Left
you are outside that window of
acceptable rhetoric sure Kanye spent
most of the 2000 saying that george w
bush was a vicious racist but now he's
out of the tent because he says that
self victimization is a disease and it's
a I think a direct quote so here is what
this this this leftist writes over at
the Washington Post quote Kanye West was
having a great weekend until he wasn't
one moment the rapper producer
entrepreneur was dispensing pearls of
pseudo philosophy on Twitter to the
retweets of adoring observers the next
many of those same admirers had turned
to denouncing him instead oh and he'd
become an all right darling whatever
West is going through at the moment the
response to his Twitter spree reveals
more about the people who have fled from
him and those who have flocked to him to
West's fortunes reversed writes this
writes this writer for The Washington
Post Molly Roberts when he expressed his
admiration on Saturday for red pill
youtuber Candace Owens an
african-american Donald Trump supporter
known for among other things referring
to black lives matter protester
as whiny toddlers pretending to be
oppressed for attention the following
day he tweeted nine videos from Scott
Adams who gained his fame first for
creating the cartoon Dilbert and second
for proclaiming that rape is a natural
instinct of men and society a virtual
prison for men's desires okay that is
taking Scott Adams wildly out of context
I believe Scott Adams is actual argument
is that natural instincts of human
beings are bad and this is why you
create civilizations which I thought was
a relatively uncomplicated and and
controversial notion in any case this is
Molly Roberts continues it's easy to
cast West is just another lost man
seduced by the far rights provides a
purpose all that pseudo philosophy does
suggest a preoccupation well the sort of
existential problems figures such as
psychologist Jordan Peterson who has
become a surprise lifestyle guru claim
they can solve it's also possible to
connect wess eccentric behavior on
Twitter this isn't the first time his
forays into politics have discomforted
some fans the mental health struggles
that led to his 2017 hospitalization so
let's get this straight Kanye West who's
reading crazy crap for most of his
career I mean I read you some of his
tweets the other day okay we're like
talking about finding antique fish tanks
right he needs an antique fish tank
talking about how he is looking for a
marble table a marble conference table
because he can't actually have a meeting
without a marble conference table hey
Kanye is the guy who tweeted I love me
some mayor I mean Kanye is is famous for
not being unhinged might be a word that
you might use in connection with Kanye
this is a guy famous for charging on a
stage in the middle of a music award
ceremony to yell at Taylor Swift and now
only now it does the left discover that
Kanye might be a bit unstable why is he
unstable because he tweeted that he
likes Candace oh and videos all right
well this is the way this is gonna go
also I love that they linked Jordan
Peterson a former professor at Harvard
University and now professor over at
University of Toronto widely widely
understood to be one of the smarter
humans alive to Kanye West that West is
just another lost man seduced by the far
rights promise to provide a sense of
purpose it's so funny how the left talks
about this they never talk about
followers of Bernie Sanders this way
Bernie Sanders promises to provide a
sense of purpose also right his sense of
purpose lies in the collective and his
sense of purpose is I will tell you how
you can help fix all of the problems of
planet Earth by giving me lots of power
and by redistributing on wealth the left
never says look at all of these Bernie
browser
these are guys who are lost looking for
something to do bored useless and now
they found a sense of purpose in Bernie
Sanders but when it comes to somebody on
the right then all of a sudden it's lost
angry young man experiencing existential
angst welcome to the real world where a
lot of people experience existential
ONC's the question is who can cater to
that in a healthy way Jordan caters to
that in a healthy way
but now they're saying that Kanye West
is a jordan Peterson devotee or
something I wish Kanye West where Jordan
Peterson devotee I mean I think it would
be really good for Kanye in fact Kanye
go over and listen to Jordan Peterson's
lectures on on the Bible on on the
Enlightenment I think that that would be
great for you but the Washington Post
says that all of this makes Kanye West
crazy so he wasn't crazy when he was
crazy he's crazy when he's conservative
and the Washington Post continues or
could it be that Kanye West is coy
stirred in a world of wealth away from
the realities of racism that motivated
incidents like his live declaration on
television after Hurricane Katrina that
George Bush doesn't care about black
people
he may be too preoccupied with his image
of himself as a truth teller to
recognize that the unconventional
communication style he finds her
attractive and Trump is just a way to
cover up lies so I love this too so
Kanye who was supremely wealthy during
Hurricane Katrina I mean the guy was
worth tens of millions of dollars by the
time of Hurricane Katrina at that point
he wasn't out of touch now he's out of
touch and you can tell that he's out of
touch because he's saying things that
Molly Roberts doesn't like in the
Washington Post
that's how you can tell right I mean you
know he's out of touch now you know he's
a member of the alt-right because he
said that self victimization is a
problem because he said that you're in
control of your own life Kanye says
these things and boom this suit is like
Hitler he is just like Hitler and now
he's not even real black person is what
Molly Roberts is really saying because a
real black person would feel an
authentic tied to his roots and Kanye
doesn't feel an authentic tied to his
roots anymore because he's become so
wealthy and so cloistered weird I
haven't heard the same thing about like
Snoop Dogg right because snoop dogg
makes videos about shooting the
President of the United States
it's noop dog is woke so snoop dogg
obviously has a tie back to the people
but Kanye has no tie back to those
people obviously because he's wealthy
right what happened is Kanye got rich
and then he was on the left but he still
had side to his people but then he was
still rich and now he is saying things
that aren't left-wing and this means
that he has lost all tied to being black
Kanye West is basically like Bill Nye
the Science Guy in blackface that's
basically what he is right now except
Bill
he's just a white guy yeah he's gone
there people who are saying he's gone to
the sunken place right which is a which
is a reference to what I thought was a
the racially polarizing movie get out
which was overlooked by all the critics
the bad racial messaging and get out was
overlooked by all the critics because
obviously it was a left-wing film The
Washington Post continues in any case
ascertaining why West thinks what he
thinks is probably as fruitless as
finding meaning in the bromines he's
been offering up the past few days all
you have to be is yourself the beauty is
in the imperfections everything you do
in life stems either from fear or love
it might be more useful to examine what
the reaction to US provocative tweets
reveal about the left and right alike so
health people reacted to west streets
okay so here is what Molly Roberts
writes in The Washington Post
progressives West more typical fan
basing greeted his return to Twitter
with breathless engagement at the moment
West expressed his approval of Owens
liberals recoiled eager to signal their
lefty credentials they withdrew their
support the moment West went against
that's the party line which sort of
sounds like this writer then there's the
right Alton otherwise most conservatives
had less interest in West's work and
they certainly didn't like it when he
condemned Bush but now a lineup of
luminaries on the right has assembled to
defend West against liberal horns where
Alex Jones once called West a microcosm
of America's degeneration he now praises
his bold moves against the thought
police where Bill O'Reilly once
described West as a disease the former
Fox host on Sunday decried the attack
against him by American stalinís okay so
first of all I would just like to point
out that Alex Jones is not really
particularly representative of the view
of the American right right you know
like Alex Jones
Alex Jones like that guy not supremely
representative of the American right
most people on the America member like
okay glad Kanye is saying some nice
stuff guys still Kanye he's weird what
what do you have to say like nothing
here okay but but you can feel all these
same things like I did an entire segment
two days ago about why conservatives
should not be over the moon about Kanye
West suddenly embracing the right-wing
agenda right at the same time I'm
defending him from American Stalinist
like this column I mean this is this
sort of thought policing Kanye West said
something bad he must be crazy he must
be a right-wing racist it's all insane
it's all insane so this Molly Roberts
concludes in the end the weekends West's
affair was a very public display of
people using other people West's hyped
up his announced album even further with
the publicity he gained from courting
controversy
liberals have shown off their
willingness to enforce ideological
purity no
matter who the offender is and the far
right has demonstrated once again
they're willing to flip-flop at the
slightest sign they might be able to
land a mainstream celebrit don't trade
your authenticity for approval west
tweeted last week too late yeah again
the left would not be complaining
because they were talking for years
about what awoke guy he was when he was
ripping into george w bush so before we
go any further honestly thanks to our
sponsors over at blue apron so blue
apron is the leading meal delivery kit
in the united states and many people
know what they do but some people don't
okay here's what they do they will send
to you these amazing recipes along with
the prepackaged purely fresh ingredients
and you can cook them with your family
in your own home it takes like 45
minutes to cook these meals and they are
gourmet they're the number one fresh
ingredient recipe delivery service in
the country and they offer a bunch of
plans they offer first of all
convenience and variety because they
deliver all of this to you on a regular
basis twelve new recipes per week
customers can pick two three or four
recipes based on what best fits their
schedule it's high-quality stuff they
send only non GMO ingredients meat with
no added hormones again everybody the
office is using blue apron because you
don't have time to go to the grocery
store you don't have time to figure out
what it is you want to cook tonight and
then try and parcel out in your mind how
much of X you need to buy instead it all
just comes right to you and you're
making fantastic recipes restaurant
quality stuff check out this week's menu
get your first three meals free at blue
aprons comm slash Shapiro blue apron
comm slash appear again I mean I'm
looking at some of the recipes they're
amazing it's like steak frite eggs with
roasted broccoli and lemon aioli
it's kung pao chicken with surf fried
snow peas and sweet peppers right stuff
that you would be paying a lot of money
at a restaurant for instead you're
cooking in your own home which is super
fun with kids particularly check it out
blue apron calm slash up here oh what's
blue apron calm slash Shapiro and you
get your first three meals free ok so
meanwhile while the West is consumed
with the saga of Kanye West I think that
it is important to to give an update on
the situation regarding Alfie Evans
who's this two-year-old child in Great
Britain
so this two-year-old child in Great
Britain almost two has been condemned to
die by the British courts his parents
want to remove him from Britain the
Italian government has sent a plane the
Italian government has said the day will
provide for his medical care in Italy
and the British government is saying no
we will not let him out this is like
Pharoah we will not let him go we will
not let him go to save his life because
he must die with dignity and we say that
death with dignity means dying in our
Hospital at our behest number one the
idea of dying with dignity is such an
salting term just the very terminology
of dying with dignity is really bizarre
because everybody is gonna die and the
suggestion that if you cling to life
that somehow you lack dignity or the
suggestion that if you meet your end be
it being sad about your impending death
that this means that you are somehow
lacking encourage that there is a
dignified way to go in the dignified way
to go is in a hospital surrounded by
people who are pumping juice into you or
alternatively the dignified way to go is
for us to unhook a baby and watch that
baby suffocate to death because the baby
can't breathe properly
doesn't seem super dignified to me you
know everybody has to face death your
choice as an adult is how to face it
but as a child there's no such thing as
dying with dignity there just isn't
because you're not capable of dignity as
a two-year-old okay I have a
two-year-old boy he's not capable of
dignity he's capable of pooping in his
pants and being cute okay this is what
my two-year-old is capable of he's
awesome I love him dignity ain't on the
menu but the idea that you're gonna take
a two-year-old who's dying of a horrible
brain disease and then say this child
has to die with dignity it's such a
stupid insulting term it's it's just a
ridiculous term and beyond that the the
arrogance of these folks to say that
they know more than the parents about
what is best for the child than what's
best for the child is to die without
this experimental treatment who the hell
are they to decide that who are they to
decide what sort of life is best worth
living the medical profession used to be
about the Hippocratic oath preserving
life as long as humanly possible now the
medical profession has become the great
arbiter of the lives that are worthy
this is true in Great Britain it's true
in the United States as well yeah people
like Ezekiel Emanuel saying he wants to
die at 80 because he doesn't want to
live with disease well that's his choice
he can do what he wants free country but
the idea that his standard for a
dignified life should be the standard
for everyone even above the wishes of
parents we're the ones who have to spend
time with their child who have to sit
the father last night was giving
mouth-to-mouth to his son because the
hospital would not give his son oxygen
okay this is evil what we're watching in
Britain it's evil and that's happening
because the buraco the the bureaucracy
the centralized bureaucracy of great
states have decided they know more than
the common man about virtue and vice
they know more about dignity and death
than the common person including a
common person who has to actually visit
the gravestone of these doctors gonna be
going to alfea's grave after the kid
dies I promise you as parents well just
horrifying
okay so meanwhile speaking of a foolish
we in the United States are consumed
with with the most important issues
here's an important issue from the New
York Times from jo-ann's Patera Mizpah
Tarot is a new york-based writer who's
engaged to a transgender woman which is
to say a man right a biological man and
here is the piece from the New York
Times because we you know the New York
Times only traffics in the most
important ideas are the things that we
all have to come to grips with as a
society
no not like religious freedom or the
value of life not stuff about what the
government ought to be involved in your
healthcare decisions no what they have
to be involved in is explaining how it
is that a woman and a man who's had some
hormone treatments can have a baby and
it's the same thing as two lesbians
magically having a baby
I just weird weird okay so here is what
it says our society may have lost its
moorings just just a little okay so
here's what the New York Times piece
from jo-ann's pateros says over the last
several months I've spent evenings
watching my fiance Lara inject herself
with smaller and smaller doses of
estrogen there again is a biological man
I've watched her stand in front of a
mirror singeing each hair out of her
face with a second hand electrolysis
machine the return of her testosterone
hasn't resulted in just the resurgence
of facial hair her pants now fit
differently to my own skin has been
plagued by acne since I got off the pill
six months ago and my default states are
angry hungry are sleeping such are the
perils of trying to have a child the way
Lara and I are trying without in vitro
fertilization or cryogenically frozen
sperm the way fertile cisgender people
do they simply couple up and boom a
child is born I'm not sure why there are
perils involved with this I've done it
twice it was great
okay let's be real about this make
babies pretty awesome people been doing
it for hundreds of thousands of years
not seeing the tough part here and not
seeing the reason we have to have a
let's look at this twelve hundred word
essay on you having sex with a dude who
thinks he's a lady not sure why that is
worthy of space in the New York Times
but all right all right I just I love
that everything if you could run a scam
right let's say it's so funny folks on
the left are constantly thinking that
you know the bible thumpers the people
who believe in things like actual
biology that these people what they're
really seeking to do is they want to
take lesbians and they want to marry
them off to men and force them into a
situation where they have to have
biological children with a male I guess
all we have to do now is declare that
the man's a woman and then
we're good right I mean this woman's a
lesbian but she's having sex with a
full-on man because the man is a woman
but not really because he says he's a
woman because he has some sort of mental
disorder man this is again worthy of
coverage in the New York Times for many
young trans people the question of
having babies is likely the last thing
on their minds who could blame them like
all young people they're figuring out
their future in matters of diapers and
breastfeeding seem abstract and far off
but unlike all young people young trans
people are often making choices that
have long-term consequences for their
fertility which is part of how I 32 year
old cisgender lesbian and Lyra my 33
year old trans fiance came to be in the
situation we're in today trying to
conceive a child even though Larra
transition nearly four years ago Elara
transitioned sort of Larra still has the
the non lira parts right lares still has
the John parts or whatever leras
previous name was her dead name as they
say I didn't even vaguely realize how I
wanted biological kills kids until my
mid-20s before then I'd vaguely imagined
that children would simply come to me
our Auntie Mame or Diane Keaton and baby
blue might inherit them from a long-lost
relative and simply slot them into my
independent modern life little did I
know that in just a few years I'd be
staying up to read studies in which
scientists combined the eggs of two
female rats to make a child hoping for
50 more years on the planet so I'd be
around when they began testing on humans
but you don't need them to combine two
female eggs you're having sex with a
dude who has sperm so that's odd
again the reason that I highlight this
is just to demonstrate that when you
cast out biological distinctions and
pretend that science is something that
science is not you end up with bizarre
notions like the idea that it's some
sort of great earth-shaking event when a
man and a woman have sex and promote and
and create a baby because the man has
been taking some hormone treatments also
this article is making a case that I
pretty sure decided this writer doesn't
want to make right which is the which is
that it may be worthwhile for
transgender people not to actually
mutilate their own genitals then it may
be worthwhile for them to keep the
genitals that they have so they can
actually procreate when they choose to
do so this is actually the the subtle
case that is being made by this article
but it's it's pretty amazing it's pretty
amazing so at the very end she Joanne's
Patera actually says that she says the
truth is some people know from the
beginning they never want kids but some
even those who thought they were sure
can one day find themselves feeling
differently especially if they meet
someone they'd love to blend genes with
these people can then find that
permanent decisions made early on may
have closed doors before they even knew
they wanted to open them so
pretty pretty interesting stuff actually
is that the the conclusion of the
article is the conservative conclusion
that you may want to wait to have
hormone treatment and mutilate your body
because you think that you're a member
of the opposite sex because you might
never know what sort of choices you want
to make later so but this is what
happens when a society decides to
purposely confuse itself about basic
concepts like what gender constitutes
okay so before I go in before I go any
for the first I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at Skillshare so
Skillshare is an online learning
platform with over 20,000 classes in
business design technology and more and
it is just fantastic we've been taking
all sorts of new classes over at scale
sure our employees have been taking
classes over at skill shares I've been
taking classes from Skillshare 45
minutes by people who really know what
they're doing we're talking about
experts in their field you can even
interact with those experts as well
so it's not quite the same things just
going and viewing a YouTube video for
seven minutes and you get like a basic
concept of what's going on you will know
what you are doing when you finish a
Skillshare class this is just the way it
works you can take classes in social
media marketing illustration data
science I've started taking one now in
photography because I already took mine
in watercolor I'm becoming a more
artistic individual okay you hear okay
so they're doing all of this and whether
you're trying to deepen that
professional skill set or start a side
hustle or just making sure the resume is
better so that if you change jobs you
get higher pay skill set is for you
skill set is for you join the millions
of students already learning on
Skillshare today with my special offer
just for my listeners get two months of
skill share for just 99 cents that's
right skill share is offering my
listeners right now two months of
unlimited access to over 20,000 classes
for just 99 cents go to skill share calm
/ capiro that is skill shared calm /
Shapiro's to start those two months
right now skill share calm / prepare
once you sign up you're gonna want to
continue it because it just is that good
yeah I know my audience loves to learn
and there's no better place to do it
than skill share skills share calm / up
hero - check it out alright so speaking
of the media's promulgation of
particular ideas about gender and
transgenderism it is pretty obvious that
this is having a significant impact on
the on the society at large now I guess
the the government is going to tell your
children how to think about these issues
so on Monday there's a feminist writer
named Jessica Valenti and she made
pretty clear why a lot of conservatives
are looking to homeschool their kids
okay she tweeted out this she tweeted
out to the folks who find
gbt language confusing if my daughter's
second grade class gets it so can you
okay and here is what the the the
picture that she tweeted out says his
lesbian a woman who has only romantic
feelings about women gay a man who has
only romantic feelings about men by a
person who has romantic feelings about
men and women why would a seven-year-old
needs to know these things you asked
because we have to indoctrinate them at
7 years old otherwise they will turn out
to be intolerant Americans transgender a
person who is assigned male or female at
birth but doesn't identify that way okay
that is so anti scientific I cannot even
begin to explain it okay you're not
assigned male or female at birth it's
not like the doctor sits there and flips
a coin and goes you know what you're a
male I just figured it out you know
we're gonna assign it to you right just
like you're given an assignment in class
no the doctor looks at the PP or the
juju and then says you are a male or a
female okay this is really not difficult
seriously
the doctor does not assign sex at birth
by the way if you're gonna say the
doctor of science sex assigns it they're
gonna have to go back to the ultrasound
because by 10 weeks you know whether
your baby's a boy or a girl in fact we
can tell even earlier than that in some
cases simply by looking at the mother's
blood stream because the baby's because
certain cells from the baby are present
in blood tests for the mother and you
can tell whether the baby is a boy or a
girl it's not a sign I mean this is this
notion that that sex is some sort of
social construct is so insane or the
gender is completely untethered from sex
it doesn't even make sense according to
the according to the advocates of
transgenderism if gender and sex are
completely untethered then why is it the
transgender people want to appear to
look like women why is it the
transgender people find it important to
use female names if all this untethered
from is untethered from sex and
completely arbitrary then wouldn't you
just assume you could be transgender
without picking up any of those cultural
stereotypes that have been created by
that patriarchal white cisgender society
and also these second graders are
learning a person who has assigned male
or female at birth and does identify
that way is a cisgender person a queer
person it's complex and can mean a lot
of things a person who doesn't identify
as straight or bi or gay or lesbian well
thanks for that clarification and
straight is a man who only has romantic
feelings about women or a woman who only
has romantic feelings about man again
I'm so glad that second graders are
learning this in Jessica Valenti's
second grade child's class very
important stuff the reason I bring this
up is because the same government that
says it gets to decide whether your
should live or die in Britain it's the
same government that gets to decide
whether your school teaches you this
propaganda or not okay so there's a
Jewish school in Britain it's now it's
been threatened for two years by the
British authorities because it is a
Jewish school meaning and they do not
want to teach propaganda from the LGBT
left they're not interested in teaching
about the moral equivalence between
heterosexual sex and homosexual sex
they're not interested in teaching about
the the socially approved ideas of
transgenderism they say that God made
men and God made women and there are
some people who are born intersex but
that's not the same thing as
transgenderism that school is now being
threatened with its licence revoked
revocation license revocation in Britain
okay so the same government that's
telling you how to raise your child is
telling you when your child has to die
centralized government is such a
nightmare this is why it sort of matters
when you when you see these pieces that
seem to be on the wild bluff because
everything that starts off on the wild
left ends up on the mainstream left
within about five minutes right the
whole goal here is indoctrination of
children and you can see this even in so
far as it there's another story that's
insane apparently according to live site
news transgender activists gathered
outside a Rhode Island Catholic Church
last week it's a Catholic Church for
God's sake to protest a lecture
delivered by pediatrician Michelle
Katella who views affirming
transgenderism and kids as a form of
child abuse okay it's a Catholic Church
what do you think she is going to say by
the way I tend to agree with this
position I tend to agree with the
position that if my two-year-old came to
me and said daddy I'm a girl and I said
to him you know what you're right kid
you're a girl
ignore all your biology you're a girl
that purposefully confusing children is
a form of child abuse Eilidh case to be
made for this Michelle certainly the
idea of generally mutilating or or
hormonal EMU t'lay ting children I think
is a form of child to be as pretty
obviously in any case
Michelle critera is president of the
American College of pediatricians and
she's made it her mission to highlight
the harmful effects of gender
transitioning on children according to
Paul Bois over at say Lee Weyer at the
time of her comments Rhode Island had
recently enacted a law stripping parents
of their right to object to providing
treatment for gender transition to
children who showed signs of gender
dysphoria
okay the Roman Island Catholic explained
the law quote last year the state of
Rhode Island made it illegal for a
licensed medical professional to counsel
away from the desire to change his or
her gender identity it remains legal to
inject that same child with hormone
blockers and cross-sex hormones
currently Rhode Island public schools
are deciding how to implement statewide
transgender policies that would open up
bathrooms locker rooms and sports teams
to anyone who claims to be the opposite
gender from their biological sex it's
one thing to argue that if you are a
parent you should be allowed to make the
terrible decision about about forwarding
your child's transgender transgender
feelings as it's a terrible decision
because studies show that well over 80%
of all children who believe they are
transgender when their children outgrow
it by the time they're teenagers
very often they end up Carol is bein hey
but the state has now mandated has now
mandated that everyone be indoctrinated
with these ideas and it's a very short
leap from here to the idea that
homeschooling itself should be legal so
a lot of Christians a lot of Jews have
started taking their kids Muslims too
and started taking their kids out of
public schools and educating their
children at home to avoid these social
leftist strictures well the state is not
going to stand for that the state is
going to say that you are not licensed
to do that and your kid is a truant and
then they will say next that if your kid
does not learn what the state wants our
kids to learn then they will take your
kid away from you and give them up to
foster care that's none Child Protective
Services I am predicting this right now
okay you can mark the date I've been
predicting this for months now you can
mark the date today's April 25th within
five years there will be a serious
movement in this country to end
homeschooling simply because everyone on
the Left believes that homeschooling is
a threat to their social values and the
case will be made that you're bringing
up kids to be intolerant you're bringing
kids to be up you bring up kids to be
cruel and nasty parental power will
shrink as the power of the state grows
anyway this woman critera dr. Kurt Ella
she was speaking at the st. Pius v
Church in Providence - and 40 LGBT
activists showed up outside and and then
they started protesting her it's it's
just astonishing again they're
protesting churches this is why when
people on the Left say why do you feel
so threatened by by all of this yeah you
can do what you want it's a free country
you'll go to whatever lefty Church you
want to go to don't go to church at all
I don't care all right be gay be lesbian
be transgender you're an adult your
decision okay as a religious person I
can think your decisions are sinful
doesn't matter it's a free country you
can think I'm an idiot
we'll tell you that once you start going
outside churches and protesting
traditional churches suggesting those
traditional churches have to change
their ways or face your wrath you're
talking about something deeply
disturbing and fistic in the extreme now
in just a second I wanna discuss the
controversy swirling around joy read
over over at MSNBC because she is now in
serious trouble but I'll explain that in
just a second first I want to say thanks
to our sponsors over at policy genius so
71% of Americans say they need life
insurance but only 59% of them have
actually gotten coverage well this is
because you're lazy okay if you haven't
gotten life insurance it's because
you're lazy it's not that expensive it's
worth looking into
and once you're dead you can't do it
anymore just like many other things
except this time your death actually
matters your family may not love you but
if you leave them bereft it will love
you even less can you want people at
your funeral go get some life insurance
okay if you've been avoiding getting
life insurance you need to go over to my
friends at policy genius it's the easy
way to compare life insurance online you
can compare quotes in just five minutes
and when it is that easy then there's no
excuse for putting it off other than
you're a do policy genius has helped
over 4 million people shop for insurance
they placed over 20 billion dollars in
coverage and they don't just make life
insurance easy they also compare
disability insurance renter's insurance
and health insurance if you care about
it they cover it so go over to policy
genius.com right now and again within
minutes you can be comparing quotes it
is the easy way to compare top insurers
and find the best value for you no sales
pressure zero hassle you can do it all
in the comfort of your own home while
you're watching Netflix policy
genius.com when it's this easy to
compare life insurance there's no reason
to put it off again policy genius.com
okay well in just a second I'm gonna
discuss the situation with joy Reid but
first you're gonna have to go over to
Daly wire.com and subscribe so daily
we're calm $9.99 a month you got the
rest of this show live today we're from
Liberty University it's an amazing
amazing setup I mean just in it when I
spoke at the convocation this morning it
was incredible incredible group of
people will put that speech up on our
YouTube page where you should subscribe
as well but if you just want these watch
the rest of the show live be part of our
mailbag on Friday then go over to Daly
we're calm subscribe $9.99 a month rest
of my show live for us too Clavin the
show live the rest of Knolls the show
live plenty more goodies coming in the
very very near future
also if we want to just follow us and
watch for free then go over to youtube
subscribe leave us a review go over to
iTunes do the same thing we always
appreciate it we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
all righty so a leading LGBT advocacy
Brook group has now rescinded its
straight for equality and Media Award
from MSNBC MSNBC host joy Reed on
Tuesday now it would be easier for me to
follow this controversy if Troy Reid had
not in fact blocked me on Twitter years
ago but it turns out that joy read years
ago around a blog and on that blog she
posted stuff that was supposedly
homophobic I went back and I read the
comments and they're not great for a
leftist but they're also not
particularly over-the-top like she says
things in is it to give you some context
she says things like the sight of two
men kissing makes her uncomfortable I'm
not sure why that's homophobic like
really I'm not sure why that's
homophobic I would assume that for gay
people watching straight people kiss is
is not something they enjoy particularly
much she says that she said that she
isn't that she didn't want to watch
Brokeback Mountain because it made her
uncomfortable again I think the whole
predicate of of our sexual freedom
society is that whatever floats your
boat which means by necessity certain
things do not float your boat which
means that you have to leave people
alone if things don't float their boat
apparently dry Reid committed some sort
of grave sin here and now she must be
cast out like a leper from the leftist
group think so Liz Owens director of
communications for PFLAG Nacional said
the group had invited Reid to honor her
at their 45th anniversary celebration
DRI reads Ben Pro same-sex marriage for
years knowing about some posts she'd
already apologized for but there were
new posts that had caused it to rescind
the invitation Owen said we appreciated
how she stepped up took ownership
apologized for them and did better this
is the behavior and approach we ask of
any ally however in light of new
information and the ongoing
investigation of that information we
must at this time rescind our award to
miss Reid
so these newly uncovered posts were
uncovered by media ight and she
responded that the that she had been
hacked that this was all the result of
hacking which is real weird this is her
big mistake is that she suggested that
she she she came out and she said that
um that these were fake right she made
the Anthony Weiner mistake you're not
allowed to make the Anthony Weiner
mistake it's one thing to post a bunch
of weird stuff and then apologize for it
later but joy Reid instead said that she
she'd been hacked which led to this
entire controversy about whether in fact
she'd been hacked the answer is probably
not right she does all this stuff had
been discovered by looking at the
internet archives wayback machine
the Wayback Machine captures websites
old websites and old posts and there is
no indicator that the wayback machine
itself had been hacked but the point
here is simply that the left is so
intolerant that no matter how much joy
read may believe that she has an ally
she is in fact not an ally right she
cannot be an ally because she said
something that people don't like 15
years ago 1215 years ago even though she
has recanted all of those particular
posts right so it's this is I think
really bad a lot of people on the right
are jumping on this and saying joy read
should lose her career try read should
be fired and listen I understand the the
satanic temptation to stomp on joy reads
grave I get it like I understand that
there are a bunch of people on the left
you say really nasty thing about the
right and if this were someone on right
I don't think joy Reid would be
defending them but I'm gonna say for the
record that I think that somebody who
had positions that they then recanted
and clearly recanted and are no longer
associated with I don't mean you keith
Ellison who continued to meet with the
Nation of Islam I mean like joy Reid who
has recanted all of her positions on
this and switched
I don't see why bringing up their old
post and then destroying their career
over it is a worthwhile thing because
the truth is you can do this about
pretty much anything anybody was in a
long career in in public is going to
have said some stuff that they're
embarrassed of anybody in public is
going to have said them things that they
wish they hadn't said some of them
change position I've changed some of my
positions over the years there's a
column I wrote in 2007 about what I term
traitorous Democrats talking about the
Iraq war that I probably wouldn't right
now right that was 11 years ago there's
a column I wrote very early in my career
about the israeli-palestinian issue in
which I suggested transfer as a
possibility for for Arab populations I
openly recounted that I think this is
true for pretty much everybody in public
life if you go back far enough you can
find something they said that they no
longer believe and destroying them over
that is a really dangerous game because
if we're gonna do that then people are
just going to hide what they believe
what you actually want from your public
from your public personas what you
actually want from opinion-makers
are their thoughts you don't want them
hiding their thoughts you don't want
them hiding the ball you want to know
what they think because that's how we
can engage with these ideas that's how
we as a side you can call out the bad
ideas and garner the good ones that's
the whole goal and again I just I find
the whole attack on joy read to be
wildly wildly silly particularly from
the left so
I'm looking at some of these I'm looking
at some of these posts right now so she
wrote a post called
charlie crist is not gay she wrote a
post apparently or this was on her
website is called Harriet Miers and the
lesbian hair track talking about Harriet
Miers is lesbian hair like really that's
the kind of stuff that you gonna ruin
her career over and says don't you sue
me Tom Cruise like making a joke about
Tom Cruise being gay because he's long
been rumored to be gay again I'm not
sure why any of this is particularly
homophobic and pretty Cowboys in love or
last gasp but gay chic was the title of
one of her pieces she says here's one of
the posts that is supposed to be just
awful awful dry read has to have a
career ended because of this quote
keeping it real most strip men feel
exactly the same way when would have the
exact same reactions he had he had
stripping naked in a sweaty locker room
in close quarters with a gay teammate
most straight people cringe at the sight
of two men kissing most straight people
had a hard time being convinced to watch
Brokeback Mountain I admit that I
couldn't go see the movie either despite
my sister's ringing endorsement because
I didn't want to watch the two male
characters having sex does that make me
homophobic probably well the truth is it
doesn't make you homophobic because
again being a homophobe just means that
you are scared of gay people or scared
of homosexual activity or presumably
that you're bigoted against homosexuals
not being into the activity does not
mean you're homophobic again if I were
the case then gay people would be
straight phobic because that logic
doesn't hold at all here's another one
of the posts that supposedly has to
finish joy Reid's career some people use
the word immoral when they really means
it's tasteful I think a lot of
heterosexuals especially men find the
idea of homosexual homosexual sex to be
well gross and they lump it in with
immorality and then there are the
concerns that adult gay men tend to be
attracted to very young post-pubescent
types bringing them into the lifestyle
in a way that many people consider it to
be immoral so that last sentence is the
one that borders on the controversial
right that last sentence where she says
that there are adult gay men who prey on
younger men you know that that's the
only section here that I find to be you
know truly truly controversial but again
joy Reid has apologized for all this
stuff in the past as a society we're
gonna have to be a little bit more
forgiving of people I mean right and
left people who have recanted prior
views because otherwise I think you just
end up in a position where nobody will
give their views openly at all about
virtually anything okay so meanwhile the
controversy has broken out without
president Trump's nominee to fill the VA
so he was not
Ronni Jackson Ronnie Jackson of course
was the White House physician and there
are a lot of bad stories they've been
breaking about Ronnie Jackson apparently
Ronnie Jackson there's report that he
was drunk on duty at one point and and
the Democrats are immediately jumping on
this here is one Democratic senator
unloading on Ronnie Jackson yesterday
they fallin in three different areas
improper dispensing of prescription
drugs repeatedly drunk while on duty
while traveling and creating a toxic
work environment by the way we had
twenty military folks and retired
military folks tell us these stories and
in the previous administration we were
told of stories there were he was
repeatedly drunk while on duty where his
main job was to take care of the most
powerful man in the world that's not
acceptable yeah so I mean there are a
lot of people who are testifying this
wasn't a great peg now I don't know that
much about Ronnie Jackson the White
House is sort of standing by him sort of
not Trump yesterday did a real weird
thing where you urged his own nominee to
bow out during a press conference which
is kind of wild here's what President
Trump had to say about Ronnie Jackson
the the White House position being
considered for VA secretary I told
Admiral Jackson just a little while ago
I said what do you need this for this is
a vicious group of people that maligned
and they do and I lived through it we
all live through it you people are
getting record ratings because of it so
congratulations but I said what do you
need it for he's an admiral he's a great
leader and they questioned him about
every little thing it's kind of weird
that Trump was urging his own nominee to
bail out I will say that the vetting of
the nominees has to be better from the
White House you actually have to go back
and look at the record picking people
that Trump personally knows for
positions doesn't seem to be working out
all that well and the administration has
been getting steadily better I mean the
staffing at the administration has been
getting better we've gotten rid of a bad
VA secretary we have gotten rid of a bad
Secretary of State we've gotten rid of a
national security advisor in favor of a
better national security adviser I think
that things that the the staff on the
whole today is much better than the
staff was on the whole a year ago that
said they kind of fly by the seat of
your pants vetting of nominees has to
stop from the Trump administration it
continues to it continues to promulgate
gay
there's a lot of chaos inside the
administration which unfortunately there
there is that said the media bias on all
of this stuff isn't saying hey Trump is
not wrong when he says that the media
are just wild about everything Chris
Chile's over at the over at CNN spent an
entire segment an entire segment of TV
analyzing an awkward handshake photo of
Donald Trump and Emmanuel macron the
president of France like an entire
segment here here here's what it
actually looked like it's so it's so
bizarre so obviously lots of people
talking about Melania Trump's hat that's
the buzz of the picture but I just want
to point one thing out people will say
oh I did I find this the political
theatrics fascinating what is going on
here and here
why is macron doing the hook em horns
it's very Simmons kiss guitarist thing
but either way it's super weird okay you
know what's super weird is that the
media are fascinated with presidential
handshakes yeah I made fun of them for
like five seconds yesterday but the
media spent full on segments yesterday
analyzing the weird dynamics between
Trump and McCrone is that says any sort
of relevance to anyone basically the
media have become TMZ so there's a movie
that's out called I Tanya and there's a
scene in the movie where there's a guy
who was working for a National Enquirer
like publication and he says that we
were staking out Tonya Harding's house
and we were covering this thing in
insane fashion providing them the model
for the mainstream media and he's not
wrong it's a joke in the movie but it's
not a joke okay this is covered the same
way that you'd cover it on the soup hey
this is covered the same exact way that
you would cover it if you were watching
TMZ and TMZ were covering this handshake
and it's happening on CNN and then
people wonder why there's significant
credibility problems with the media and
speaking of credibility problems of the
media there was a piece that came out
from the Washington Post yesterday that
was a picture of three reporters they
Ashley Parker April Ryan who's the the
black reporter from the African American
news network whose name I can't recall
and and the third person was at Jim
Acosta the insufferable Jim Acosta from
CNN and they are all standing there and
doing a hero shot looking off in
resistance the entire article is about
heroic these members the media are in
the face of the Trump administration
okay they're not Solzhenitsyn they're
literally getting front-page photo
spreads in mainstream American
newspapers I'm supposed
to believe that these people are victims
the media are so enthralled with
themselves over over their own behavior
under the Trump administration
no wonder Trump is tempted to just spit
in their eye on a regular basis I can't
blame him for that I can blame him for
picking people without vetting them but
I can't blame him for spitting in the
item media because the media really are
wild okay time for a thing I like and
then we'll do a thing that I hate so
first the thing I like so yesterday on
the plane I had the chance to watch only
the brave I really have chances to watch
movies only when my wife is working late
at the hospital or when I'm on a plane
so I watched only the brave only some of
it on the plane yesterday it's really
good movie was first recommended to me
actually by my friend Dana Perino and
she raved about it it's worth it's worth
the rave it's it's really solid here's a
little bit of the trailer from only the
brave I work this plays nearly 110 and
the blink of an eye just fire everywhere
and then charging out of these flames
comes this bear on fire was most
beautiful and terrible thing I've ever
seen
I heard you guys had some slots
available you lost got one slide open
you know what we're training for
hotshots get to engage the fire directly
the SEAL Team six with fire fun if you
give me a chance I won't let you down
sooner or later the fire is gonna come
out get in our home - been trying it for
over four years and got all our hours
all our qualifications but until we're
certified hotshots my crew won't even be
able to set foot on the line I told it
would be easy okay so the movie is is
quite good it's really effective I think
it's it's quite moving so check it out
if you haven't a chance to yet check out
only the brave okay time for a thing
that I hate so yesterday I didn't have
time to to pay tribute to the Armenian
Genocide simply because we ran out of
time on the show but I want to do it
today so yesterday marked the the
opening of the Armenian Genocide the
Armenian Genocide was actually a series
of genocides and they were basically
religious wars by Muslims against
Christians okay let's be real about this
the Armenian Genocide had to do with
ethnicity but it also had a large
component to do with religion you know
on yesterday's date in 1915 hundreds of
Armenians intellectuals Christians for
the most part were forcibly deported
from the Turkish capital of
Constantinople the number of soon
escalated into the thousands most were
eventually murdered that kicked off the
Armenian Genocide the persecution of
Christians Armenians by Muslim young
turks who wanted to cleanse the new
country of the troublesome non
co-religionists in preparation for the
new regime in Turkey in the aftermath of
the collapse of the Ottoman Empire by
the time the genocide was over it lasted
from 1915 all the way to 1923 hundreds
of thousands of Armenians were dead top
range estimates put the number at 1.5
million and there are massive atrocities
we're talking about putting our meaning
in children on boats and then sinking
them in in lakes we're talking about
forced death marches or talk about mass
shootings CNN reports the death toll is
in dispute but photograph from the era
document some mass killings some show
Ottoman soldiers posing the severed
heads others with them standing amid
skulls in the dirt the victims are
reported to have died in mass burnings
by doing and by drowning tortured gasps
poisoned disease and starvation children
reporters have been loaded onto boats
taken out to sea and thrown overboard
and of course rape was frequently
reported now what's amazing is that so
many countries still refused to use the
term Armenian Genocide the United States
and Israel among them both of those
countries should immediately use the
term Armenian Genocide it is absurd not
to recognize the truth of the Armenian
Genocide and not to recognize also that
the Armenian Genocide was the
predecessor for the Holocaust the
current dictator of
Turkey who is in Islamist himself Recep
Tayyip Erdogan and a terrorist supporter
and a radical Muslim has threatened
multiple foreign countries if they use
that in 2010 everyone openly warned he
could throw a hundred thousand Armenian
immigrants out of Turkey he said there
are currently 170,000 Armenians living
in our country only seventy thousand of
them are Turkish citizens but we are
tolerant tolerating the remaining
100,000 if necessary I may have to tell
these 100,000 to go back to their
country because they are not my citizens
I don't have to keep them in my country
so when I say that the Armenian Genocide
was the predecessor for the Holocaust
there were German staffers I mean the
Germans were allied with the Ottomans in
World War one there were German staffers
in the army who were present at the
happening of the Armenian Genocide
I had Hitler's confidence as schmuely
but a point out learned from Turkey's
genocidal playbook his lead political
adviser Hitler's lead political adviser
was max or when von Schuch nur Richter
who's a young German consular office in
Ayers Iran during World War one which
was a region of Turkey populated with
Armenians turkeys ethnic cleansing in
World War one was well known and admired
by Nazi ideologues in 1923 journalist
Hans Trapster wrote in the Nazi
newspaper hi Midland these bloodsuckers
and parasites Greeks and Armenians have
been eradicated by the Turks and of
course they're in in one of his speeches
Hitler apparently this is sort of
controversial but he apparently made
reference to the Armenian Genocide if
the world didn't care when the Turks
were slaughtering the Armenians they're
not going to care when we go after all
of our enemies so it is important to
recognize genocides when when they are
occurring it is important particularly
in an era of continued religious
conflict to recognize the religious
components out of the Armenian Genocide
as well okay I want to take one second
here and analyze the Federalist paper we
missed it this week so Federalist 25 we
were all the way up to Federalist 25
this one is written by Alexander
Hamilton and in this Federalist paper
Hamilton is still talking about the
necessity for common defense he's still
talking about why we ought to have a
standing army at the national level he
makes a couple of arguments that are
really interesting so his first argument
makes him sense he says we need a
standing army because if somebody
attacks us and we don't have a standing
army
we're screwed okay that's pretty obvious
but then he makes another argument that
I think we'd be welted to take in mind
he says that a national standing army
would be better than standing armies on
behalf of the states why he says the
liberty of the people would be less safe
in this state of things than in that in
which the National forces were left in
the hands of the national government as
far as an army may be considered Dane as
ad
weapon of power and had better be in
those hands of which the people are most
likely to be jealous than in those of
which they are least likely to be
jealous for it is a truth which the
experience of Ages has attested that the
people are always most in danger when
the means of injuring their rights are
in the possession of those of whom that
they entertain the least suspicion has a
really deep point you know I'm fisk
aided by some of the language here but
what Hamilton is actually saying is that
you should distrust the national
government he's saying the reason that
you can trust the national governments
we have a standing army is because you
distrust the national government to do
the right thing which means that if they
do the wrong thing people will leave the
army or people in the states will rise
up and resist them furthermore he says
people are always in the most danger
when the means of injuring their rights
are in the hands of friends this is 100%
true it's one of the reasons why I think
even my own political viewpoint has
changed over the years I was much more
kind of traditionally conservative and
less libertarian when I was 19
than I am now one of the reasons is
because when you're a young conservative
growing up under the Bush administration
you figure okay I like George W Bush I
don't mind that the government has more
power and then Obama becomes present you
say well this kind of sucks I don't like
that the government has this much power
and then the question becomes okay when
you have a Republican again they're
gonna go back to the idea that power is
only a matter of who uses it or you're
gonna say that there's an inherent risk
to the national government having the
kind of power that can be wielded by
your political enemies and therefore we
should minimize that amount of power and
that's what Hamilton is really saying
underneath the surface there okay so
we'll be back here tomorrow with more
again it's been just an honor to be here
at Liberty University what an incredible
institution it is the kids here are just
amazing and I can't speak highly enough
about what the students here are doing
for their community and for the world
just a terrific terrific University I
will be back here tomorrow I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and arrow
audios mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua Oliveira the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright for
publishing 2018